you must be so proud of mal then when
you first met her getting her to crack a
smile was the biggest challenge of all
but now malli is ready to become your
queen and help the people of auradon and
the isle live together in harmony you
and mal are meant to be we love how you
always honor her VK history and leave
your people with an open heart and mind
you and mal are the king and queen
auradon deserves wrong with everybody
no offense Audrey there's no simpler way
to put it we love The Descendants movies
more than anything there are so many
iconic scenes that we still can't get
over
so we've collected the top ten best
scenes from The Descendants franchise
and believe us when we say these scenes
changed everything Doug to the rescue
the first descendants film is loaded
with memorable scenes that teach us a
lot about life but if there's one
unforgettable scene it's the one that
takes place in chemistry class Evie was
taught that beauty and status were
everything and it took being betrayed by
Chad charming for her to realize what
life was truly about Evie used her magic
mirror to look smart in chemistry class
but that totally backfired on her when
Chad stole her mirror and told the
teacher everything seconds before a
chemistry test no less the teacher was
going to recommend expulsion but Doug
was having none of that
before Evie could defend herself it was
Doug to the rescue he lay a doesn't fare
obviously she wasn't cheating since you
didn't have that whatever it is and then
the teacher agreed to give Evie a second
chance if she could pass the exam on her
own for the first time ever
Evie had to take a chemistry exam
without cheating and she got a b-plus
Doug helped Evie realize that she was
more than just a pretty face
Doug's actions changed everything for
the wide-eyed v-k this moment marks the
beginning of their beautiful
relationship a change of heart
another amazing scene from descendants
happens midway through the movie
every die-hard fan will agree that it's
a major tipping point for mal ever since
mal was a kid all she wanted to do was
impress her mom by becoming the baddest
villain of them all
mal is convinced that if she becomes
Ben's girlfriend he'll invite her to his
coronation where she'll be within arm's
reach of fairy godmothers wand and since
bringing down the barrier is her top
priority mal brews a love potion her
magical love cookies totally work
leading them to declare his love for her
during the tourney game mal never once
expected to start having feelings for
Ben but that's exactly what happens on
their date at the enchanted lake now
goes on to sing it only while Ben is
taking a dip and it's here that she
reveals that she wants to be with Ben
despite her villain ancestry this moment
changed everything because it made mal
realize she wanted to be good for hearts
as one our last top favorite moment from
the first descendants film has got to be
the one where mal turns her mother into
a lizard not only does they show how
powerful and brave mal truly is but it
also shines a light on how much growth
the core for have experienced before
coming to Oregon mal evj and Carlos
weren't exactly BFFs they plotted
against each other in the name of evil
but the coronation scene just goes to
show how much their values have changed
mal spent her entire life wanting to
prove herself to Maleficent but when the
opportunity came up now chose to go
against her mom she chose to protect
what she had sworn to destroy and her
friends all risk their lives to save the
people of auradon even if that meant
never seeing their parents again
this moment was huge
[Music]
it proved what then had so strongly
believed in all along that kids
shouldn't be blamed for their parents
actions then and the Pirates King Ben is
a reasonable guy which is why he chose
to bring four V K's to auradon as a
start I've decided that the children on
the Isle of the Lost be given a chance
to live here and over time he planned on
bringing more decays over once the
people of auradon realized that they
weren't dangerous but it wasn't until
Emma and her pirates kidnapped Ben and
tied him to a pole that he realized he
made a big mistake then wound up being
used as leverage by uma when he wandered
into the Isle of the lost looking for
mal mal realized that she would never
fit in at auradon so she dumped Ben and
went back to the Isle in a hurry evj
Carlos and Ben went back to the aisle to
get mal which ultimately got been
kidnapped but this was all necessary in
the grand scheme of things after
spending some time with Emma then
realised that she was a resourceful
ruler who was simply misunderstood if it
hadn't been for this scene then would
have never been able to talk Emma into
retreating at the end of descendants to
mal goes full dragon one of the most
surprising scenes of descendants two
occurs at the end of the sequel when mal
turns into a dragon before that moment
not even mal knew that she had the power
to transform into a dragon just like her
mother
in the first descendants film we find
out that when it comes to magic mal is
just as gifted as her mom but we never
could have imagined that mal had
shape-shifting abilities in the bag when
uma crashes the cotillion with Ben on
her arm
now get so angry she sees green but it
takes Emma turning into a giant octopus
for Mau to transform herself
this scene changed everything because it
proved that mal was stronger than she
thought it also set up the events of
descendant 3 thanks to mal being of the
fire-breathing variety she was able to
defeat Audrey at the end of the three
kuo now let's jump right in to the five
most groundbreaking moments of
descendants three oh yes the Royal
proposal mal knew that she was engaged
engaged but she never once thought that
King Ben would propose to her the way
that he did in descendants three then
popped the big question at the beginning
of the three will which set off a wicked
chain of events just like mal Audrey
wasn't expecting to see Ben get down on
one knee which is why she reacted the
way she did while it was a long shot
Audrey still believed that she could win
Ben back up until that very moment so
yeah Sun and Mouse engagement was a
trigger for the queen of mean if then
had him proposed the way he did Audrey
never would have stolen the crown and
the sceptre from the museum and the
sleep spell would never have run its
course in auradon then totally should
have warned Audrey of his intentions
after all she was clearly still in love
with him he owed her that much and an
apology too but hey love makes you do
crazy things right the queen of mean
there's no use denying it the queen of
mean is the biggest hit from The
Descendants franchise it's even made it
into the Billboard Hot 100 which is no
small feat but for Audrey to deliver the
best solo of all she had to get her
heart broken and in public too yeah
especially for you really funny talk
about embarrassing after realizing that
she would never become the queen of
auradon Audrey set out on a little
mission all she wanted to do was steal
the Queen's crown to prevent mal from
wearing it but Maleficent sceptre sensed
Audrey's evil intentions and called out
to her many of us knew that Audrey would
be the villain of descendants three and
this scene proved them right the
two-faced princess went from being
Gordon's go to mean girl to being the
biggest threat the kingdom had ever
faced
but just because Audrey's actions came
from a place of hurt doesn't mean that
we feel bad for her because well Audrey
seemed more interested in being the
queen of auradon than Ben's wife now
comes clean if you found yourself
feeling disappointed in mal throughout
descendants
you're not alone a lot of us couldn't
believe that mal would recommend closing
the barrier for good to keep the people
of auradon save these Stambaugh were
terrified of how people would react when
they found out that the scepter had been
stolen they couldn't afford to let any
more villains out so they chose to shut
down the program but as it turns out
this sleep spell was created by an A K
and not a VK to get umma Harry and Gill
to help her save auradon now lied and
said that she would bring all the B Ches
to auradon
but once mal began to vibe with uma she
started to feel the heat after leaving
the cottage in the woods mal chose to
come clean the kids won't be coming off
the aisle what do you mean the program
is shut down
now his confession led to celia
destroying the ember which literally
changed everything
Hades does the right thing Hades isn't
the type of person to go out of his way
for anyone unless they want to strike a
deal of course but after crossing paths
with his daughter mal KT starts to have
a change of heart
sure he hates auradon and everything it
stands for as much as the next villain
but helping Audrey out of the goodness
of his heart just goes to show that
villains can be good too
Hades is brought in to Audrey's room in
Chains which is super belittling for the
god of the underworld but he pays it no
mind instead of taking the Ember and
using it to bring down the barrier
Eadie's uses it to save Audrey and then
gives his precious Ember to meld that's
a huge step for a villain to make Edie's
willingness to cooperate shows mal and
the others that villains are simply
misunderstood this telltale moment
proves that the good guys and the bad
guys can live together in harmony
now makes things right but the number
one moment of descendants three that
changed everything for the people of
auradon and the Isle has to be when mal
takes down the barrier after defeating
Audrey and retrieving Hades from the
Isle to revive her the BK's are sent
back to the Isle for good but before the
AKS can get used to the idea
mal decides to make things right I can't
be queen of just pour it on I
have to be queen of the Isle - in the
end mal explains that there's good and
bad in all of us and that we never know
where the villains and heroes are going
to come from now points out that without
uma and our Pirates auradon would be no
more and that without Hades Audrey would
still be fast asleep this moment will go
down in Oregon history as it marks the
beginning of a new era what is your
favorite moment from The Descendants
franchise tell us which one in the
comments and don't forget to explain why
and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to the things
thanks for watching we'll catch you
later
[Music]